Hello guys, Commissioner Suresh Chaudhary and
watching products, so this is
going to be mixed, there are going to be many stars of this machine learning,
now inside this we are going to
talk about the basic and fundamental of
mixing the machine, so you can see here.
What is machine learning of water?
How do we feel the weakness in the month?
We will learn about many things
not about returns in machine learning
and this video is a serious and video,
it is basically for those people
who are ignorant.  Want to learn machine learning from
and for those who are going into data science
and in today's video we are going to talk about the
basic of machine learning what are
machines and cough Scott and
machinery so let's get started
that its gas lets  With Bashir Bigg Boss
Topic
The Machine Learning Pt. So he was
excited in 1969 when he came from the cigarette machine, whose name
was Thursday, which is basically an artificial
intelligence
subscribed machine,
in which someone else's and soon
how can you pass Trikoot.  Acting in such a way that
starts self-learning without any human being alone without any
support
means it should be named as a program of something,
its powder will be made and a
button will come, it is not given
but that can be acquired by the bot without
code.  Do Madina Program, you can open it
but how Home let's see it
in the next time Experts have said about this machine learning,
you are not a machine, what is it that when the
machine starts looking fine on its own, it
means that the data which is from the old data.  He has collected
some parts of his
experience which you were giving him and you were telling him that the
program is a bit bad, which I
told him that it is set off according to Russia,
now work accordingly,
LIC itself is selling it to him.  Replacing That Was
n't
Purpose None S Machine Learning and
Application of Artificial Intelligence in
Machine Learning From the Best Experiences
From Do
Subscribe
and
Performance List
A Text Diamond Decoration for Boys
A Puppet Understanding We Can Take the
Example of Our Paper Scissors  Okay, let's take an
example of rock paper scissor, so how can we
support it, more than a prop in making games, and
we will replace the machine, look at
Faluda
monasteries and others on paper, so how will
we develop it, improve the neural network
which can draw the lines and hand.  And coordinate so let's
check the paper date
sirvi oak oak
you imagine now we are playing with him after getting him recognized from the computer if
this thing fails completely then
understand this process and be able to play and this is
non  Now there is machine learning,
so I imported my Singh data in it.
If you support, I will
keep adding thousands of images to it. Then subscribe to us.
You have replaced your handset and even the
computer can replace it. Then
Aishwarya went to a big company and got a big company.
Scalp is being made a PM in which
a lot of people on the screen of WhatsApp have
different skin tone. If he was able to do
so much music in it, along with this, it happens to
some people and he makes the paper like this,
then all this together, that if  You have to set a subscription that
on this occasion, gift to 200 people but that's
not paper, salute to this,
great to train all of them
and then to implement it -
to this is I, this machine, to give them
45410 examples of pesticide game.  The
show is called this, machine learning is
based on its
application, machine fighting voice at national
sentiment and delicious food channel, at this
interval, sperm job is available, some such
images which would have been useless to you but end up in flowers,
so how does this happen?
All this is a good choice for machine learning and
that the various types of animal mother
soft supervisor corporation supervisor learning
and reinforcement learning, we will
see about these things in half the videos,
so thanks, follow the development office, at the most half an
inch, we are basic  Send
is fundamentals for machine learning and it is going to be very easy, it is not general, you
can learn machine learning very quickly, it is not a machine, what are the
birds, okay okay no, vitamins are going to come,
how do we work in this, how can we
channel  Stabilizer Data and Credit The Future
Predictions
You will get to learn a lot of things.
In the meantime, share as much as possible
with your friends and
subscribe and follow this dish
and understand the whole series and watch it. If you
like it then like it.  Do Share
Subscribe Thank You Is A That